envuelta en smog la puerta de india un
memorial de guerra en nueva delhi apenas
está visible la calidad del aire en la
capital india es tan baja que puede
perjudicar a las personas sanas y
afectar gravemente a las que padecen
enfermedades
ahora nos enfrentamos a muchos problemas
debido a la contaminación una sensación
de ardor en los ojos asfixia al llevar
una máscara las familias no pueden estar
sanas la gente termina teniendo
problemas respiratorios con
lacapital iniesta atravesando una crisis
de contaminación atmosférica cada vez
más grave exacerbada por el aumento de
la quema de residuos de las cosechas las
emisiones del transporte las centrales
de carbón y otras industrias la
peligrosa y niebla tóxica llevó a las
autoridades a cerrar las escuelas
durante una semana así como las obras de
construcción por cuatro días el gobierno
de delhi lleva años prometiendo limpiar
el aire de la ciudad pero en la
conferencia sobre el clima con 26 inia
fue la que presionó para atenuar el
lenguaje en torno a los combustibles
fósiles
con china pidió a los países que
reduzcan en lugar de eliminar el carbón
en el tema del carbón china e india- por
supuesto van a tener que justificar a
algunos de los países más vulnerables al
clima lo que sucedió y escucharon esa
excepción en la plenaria en la cumbre
india prometió alcanzar las cero
emisiones netas en 2070 pero el país
sigue dependiendo en gran medida de los
combustibles fósiles según la asociación
internacional de la energía el carbón
generó casi el 70 por ciento de su
electricidad a finales del año pasado